all right hello everyone I'm going to
talk today about dependable real-time
decision making in cyber-physical
systems and I'll this talk is is about a
set of projects related projects done
with several students postdocs and
collaborators at Berkeley and elsewhere
and all of it is is about this class of
systems that we call cyber physical
systems so what are cyber physical
systems
well they these are integrations of
computation with the physical world and
there are several examples all around us
automotive systems avionics going from
large aircraft to little drones power
grid building control systems and so on
and so forth
and in this particular talk I'm going to
focus mostly on a class of CPS that are
often termed safety critical CPS so
these are things where the operation of
these systems usually has a component
that relates to safety broadly defined
and so these include systems like
autonomous vehicles aircraft of various
kinds even power grid you can imagine
has safety critical aspects to it and
Richard Murray actually gave a very very
nice talk
overview talk about this class of
systems and the challenges and open
problems around these in the open
lecture at the end of January so those
of you who are there recall the various
things that he brought up about these
now if you think about making these
systems dependable this is a problem
that you have to address at many layers
and and so one of the things that you
might want to do is there may be certain
very crucial components of the system
that you would like to design correct by
construction these are things that you
might like to write a formal
mathematical specification of and then
derive the implementation
that speck in a manner that preserves
correctness guarantees so you're able to
prove that the system is correct this is
definitely the Holy Grail in fact to
design the entire thing but that's
beyond our reach and today as Richard
mentioned in his talk you can apply
controller synthesis only to some very
small components of the entire CPS so
what to do about the rest well one thing
you could do is for certain other parts
of the system you could apply what we
call design time verification so maybe
these are designed by programmers
working by hand you may have third-party
components some of which you may have
the source code for and there are a
number of techniques to be able to
verify properties of these systems
before you deploy them still the state
of the art of verification is not at the
point where we want it and so so you
need something more there will always be
components today that have not been
verified now for these we need to be
able to monitor them at runtime and then
build in techniques for error resilience
or fault tolerance or maybe attack
tolerance at runtime and so there's a
slew of techniques to deal with that but
even so even runtime monitoring systems
may prove inadequate when you don't
understand the fault models or the error
models or the the situations they may
lead to failure well enough to build in
the runtime monitoring at design time
and so you also need to think about
building in systems that learn about
changes in the environment and and have
the system adapt to those changes ok so
there's many levels of many layers of
dependability here and in this talk I
will probably talk about only a few of
these in fact focusing mainly on number
one but there are that there's a very
interesting line of work that combines
techniques from formal methods design
automation cyber-physical systems
control theory programming languages and
so on that address all of these and I'm
happy to talk to people offline about
the things that I know about each of
these bullets ok so so now in the
in the next few minutes I want to give
you a sense of some of the problems in
this area so-and-so problem class is
really and one of these is robot control
and motion planning and so I don't know
if that video already started playing
but let me go back and so here if you if
you squint you'll see that's it's a
simulation video for drone flying around
a simulated neighborhood which is
pictured over here okay and so you may
have high-level objectives like there's
these blue dots you want to visit every
waypoint the blue dot at least once
while maintaining a safe distance from
obstacles and now the question is from
from writing a high level Dexter native
specification like that you'd like to be
able to synthesize the control sequence
for the drone that that you know drives
it through that achieves those obstacles
those those I'm sorry those
specifications in a provably correct
fashion okay and so that's the problem
from a declarative high-level spec how
do you synthesize the low-level control
for the robot so as to meet the
specification one of the the uses for
this is what I'll call real-time
programmability
so you folks at robotics know how to do
this already by doing low-level
programming but what they'd like to do
is raise the level of abstraction to a
point where you can write programs even
an end-user can write programs in a
simple language and then the compiler so
to speak takes care of all the the
low-level implementation for you while
preserving correctness and you want to
be able to do this imagine you're if
there's a you know a real estate agent
who's surveying a property they'd want
to be able to program the drone to do
various things at a very high level and
then reprogram it on the fly for
different properties right without
having to deal with the low-level
details ok so that's that's one class of
problems another class of problems has
to do with verification and monitoring
so in the CPS industry today especially
in safety critical applications there's
a there's a wide use of simulation
a lot of it is actually undirected but
increasingly people are using directed
simulation where they write their
desired properties in a notation that is
derived from temporal logic which is a
specification language that's proved
quite effective in hardware and software
and so what I'm going to show you here
is some use of the simulation based
verification that we have in a lab here
at Berkeley in a coarse undergraduate
course where the objective of the lab is
to drive a little robot this is a
programmable version of the Roomba there
to climb but ramp while not falling off
and avoiding obstacles and all of that
and when we took this class online in a
MOOC on EDX few years ago we designed a
virtual simulator which I'll also play
here and this had built in Auto grading
and feedback that was based on
simulation based verification of
temporal logic now the connection of
this to this particular program is that
the output of the simulator for
verification purposes is a time series
it's data all right it's a stream of
values of the state of the robot in its
environment at at various time points
and you have to be able to monitor this
stream more to the proper the the
property the triple logic property over
the stream and be able to give feedback
to the students and at EDX they told us
that you have to be able to provide
feedback on the order of a minute or
less otherwise students will tune out
right so there's this so it's a real
time in the sense that if you want to
maintain student engagement you make
sure we have to make sure that the
verification algorithm is actually
working fast enough to give them
feedback online okay so this is an this
is a class of problems where you it's
related to computing on streams where
what we're doing is monitoring a
property over time and you want to be
able to do this with ideally with a
constant amount of effort in terms of
space and time for every sample okay the
final class of applications has to do
with security in CPS
particularly secure state estimation and
secure localization so the problems here
are imagine that you have a large system
with a number of sensors and many of
these sensors are exposed to attackers
and the attacker can actually you know
physically take control of sensors or
you know or cause them to essentially
report bad values which don't meet any
fault model it could be arbitrarily bad
and now the the goal is you want your
control algorithm to be able to detect
which sensors were attacked and then
isolate them and then reconstruct the
state using the available good sensors
right so that's the secure state
estimation problem in localization it's
a similar situation where the you may
have there may be a robot that's trying
to localize itself but some of the
sources of data of like you know ground
stations might be compromised and it has
to be able to isolate those and then
localize itself accurately enough with
the remaining and these have to happen
in real time so hopefully if there's
time permits I'll show you a little demo
of what we've done with secure state
estimation doing this in near real-time
for a drone okay so for the rest of the
talk my outline is as follows I want to
give a very high-level view of the the
challenge and in CPS and this is mostly
for people who haven't are not having
looked at the a field of CPS or hybrid
systems before and then I want to dive
into one specific set of techniques that
we have been developing over the last
couple of years that show a lot of
promise this is something we call
satisfiability modular convex
programming in effect it's it's marriage
between sat solving which is proved very
effective for hardware and software
verification and convex optimization
which of course has a number of
applications in a variety of areas and
the class of problems we're looking at
actually have characteristics where you
need to combine both of these so I spend
most of my time talking about that and
then I conclude with some future
directions and I just want to mention
that the work that I talk about today is
is mostly based on a paper that appeared
about a year ago so so hybrid systems
are those that combine discrete and
continuous dynamics so think state
machines for the discrete dynamics
and differential equations for the
continuous dynamics and and over the
last two three decades there's been a
variety of tech theory techniques and
tools built for design and verification
of hybrid systems and one of the big
challenges in this area is building
reasoning engines that can reason about
both discrete variables and continuous
variables in high dimension okay so
there's two broad classes of approaches
that people use to design and verify
these systems so the first class I'll
call abstraction based techniques and
the idea here is take the continuous
part of the system and discretize it
okay so you've got your hybrid system
which has your the red part which is the
discrete part and the blue part which is
the continuous part you essentially take
the blue part and carry out some form of
abstraction to discretize the state
space then you take the product of the
two discrete components and you explore
them using existing techniques for for
verification of discrete systems okay
there's a variety of techniques for that
the challenge here is that if the
continuous part is is large and
complicated then the corresponding
discrete abstraction explodes and then
you're not able to do very much on the
other hand there's another class of
techniques which are broadly you can
think of them as optimization based and
these go the other way you take your
discrete part of the system and you
continue eyes it so to speak
so you two have your hybrid system you
take your discrete system and you encode
it in some optimization formulation and
then you you solve that using existing
optimization techniques and and we've
done there's a is a variety of work in
this area including some by by me and
Richard in our students and and this
does well as long as the discrete side
of the system is not too complicated
okay so now what to do when you have
systems where both the discrete and the
continuous part are complex in high
dimensional okay and so that's where we
started this work and we thought well
you know in the discrete world sat
solving even though this is an
np-complete problem
in theory it's it's known to be a hard
problem in practice sat solving is used
for a variety of industrial applications
routinely right and so so that's an a
very effective technique for for
reasoning about discrete systems on the
other side we have convex optimization
which is which is an excellent tool for
continuous systems and so is there a way
to combine these two right so we're
trying to basically build a new class of
solvers that essentially combine the
best of that solving with convex
optimization so it motivate this I'm
going to go back to this robot motion
planning application so imagine that you
have a robot that's that starts out at
this point the red star and it's
oriented that way and it has to get to
the Blue Square okay and the black
regions are obstacles okay so now the
question is how do i generate a sequence
of control actions to drive the robot to
the blue square so a very popular
approach is to discretize the the
physical work space so you can use your
own favorite discretization so here
there's a polygonal styling that's been
shown and and then you basically the
idea here is that each region is
designed so that the robot can navigate
from any point in this region to any
other point okay and and there's there
is there is a controller for that okay
so so you come up with this with styling
and you can represent that the the tiled
region as a grass where every region
here becomes a node and then you add an
edge between two nodes if they share a
boundary here okay and so now if I want
to get to the Blue Square which is by 28
there then it then you can think of it
as a graph for each ability problem
right and I have in particular in this
place in this workspace I have three
routes one going through the middle one
going that way in one going this way
okay but that's in the discrete world
and not all of these three routes may be
feasible when you take the robot
dynamics into question in particular it
might be that this route this gap here
is too narrow for the robot and
navigates reliably through and the same
thing here
and so in fact the only feasible route
is actually through the middle okay and
so how do you do that well the idea here
is that we want to be able to do some
discrete reasoning over this space and
then combine that with some reasoning
over the the continuous dynamics to know
which of the the parts in the graph to
the the gold state are actually not
feasible they're not consistent with the
with the dynamics okay
so here's one encoding of the problem
okay we will introduce a boolean
variable indicator variable to to
indicate which region we're at and at
which time point so the superscript
refers to time and the subscript refers
to the region so at time zero you are
the start location and at time capital L
you want to get to the goal location
okay and and then if you're at time J
you're at region I then a J plus 1 you
can end up in one of the neighboring
regions okay and then at any time point
you are not only in exactly one of those
regions so those are all boolean
constraints then you've got constraints
that deal with the robot dynamics okay
and then finally you have a constraint
that links the two which says that if at
time J I'm in region I then it must be
that the position the physical position
of the robot at time J lies in the
polygon corresponding to region I ok so
so that's the sort of problem you end up
with it's a feasibility question where
you have a boolean part you have a part
which is a conjunction of convex
constraints and then you have a part
which mixes the two alright now this is
the formulation we had for the robot
motion planning question but when we
look at a number of applications
including secure state estimation we
found they all share this common
structure which we call monotone
satisfiability modulo convex formulas
which is they really have these these
these components in particular if you
think about the overall formalize a
circuit and you push all the negations
to the leaves of the circuit then
none of the convex constraints get
negated that's where the term monitor
one comes from so there's many
applications of this like I mentioned
there's the original obstacle avoidance
I talked about you can do motion
planning with temporal logic objectives
you can do motion planning with with
many robots that have to coordinate with
each other in CPS security there's a
variety of applications including secure
traffic routing when you have vehicle to
vehicle communication and some vehicles
are dishonest but the core technique is
is this thing we call satisfiability
modular convex programming so let me
tell you a little bit about how it works
now if you think about it at a high
level
well the satisfiability question the
feasibility question for this class of
problems is equivalent to the
feasibility problem for taking a finite
disjunction of convex programs right you
can just blast this out into disjunctive
normal form the problem is you don't
want to do that because that will that
representation is likely to be
exponential and so the alternative is
something that we commonly use in the
formal methods world which is to combine
a Sat solver with something that reasons
about the underlying variables in your
underlying domain okay in this case the
convex programming tool and so the way
this works is we first take our original
formula and we separate it into a
boolean part and and the rest of it and
the way we do that is we add variables
these boolean variables that correspond
to each convex constraint okay so so in
addition to the original B variables
we'll add a new set of a variables and
this boolean eyes part will be over the
a and B variables all right and and and
both of these are equal satisfiable
right so and now what we're going to do
is we'll take that formula which is over
the the a and B variables as well as the
the continuous variables X variables and
then we combine a Sat solver with a
convex programming a convex solver but
the convex solver needs to be able to
generate certificates of infeasibility
okay and so the way this works is the
SAC solver takes just the boolean IIST
skeleton it produces a satisfying
assignment
and then it passes that over to the
convex solver which will then look at
the a variables and pick out all the
constraints that correspond to the AI is
being true all the active convex
constraints it will construct a convex
program and try to solve it if that's
feasible we're done we have a solution
if it's not feasible then it has to
produce a so-called certificate of
unsatisfiability which says you know
what's the reason that convex program
was infeasible okay and and this process
iterates until and you either report
sack or unset okay and and one of the
things is that the trivial certificate
is simply to take the conjunction of all
the AIS that corresponding correspond to
the active constraints which were found
to be infeasible and just negate them so
you get a clause which is which is the
negation of all the corresponding AIS
and you just report that back to the Sat
solver and say don't repeat this convex
program again right but but this tends
to be you know have in practice have a
lot of redundant variables in it and so
the whole game here is in order to be
able to solve this you know in real time
in control of a robot you you want
something that is smart about ruling out
these infeasible constraints okay and so
overall the complexity of the loop is
basically the number of iterations of
the loop times the time spent in the Sat
solver times the time spent in the
convex solver and even though in theory
Sat is hard in practice these problems
are that we've encountered are not too
large and they sort of have the same
form that that the so-called industrial
start instances have for other
applications where it's effective okay
and so so here the the key is how do you
reduce the number of iterations the
first thing is to notice that finding
this is np-hard in general the finding
the the the minimum the minimal on Sat
certificate but it turns out that the
class of problems we are looking at has
some interesting structure and so what
I'm showing you on the slide is that
there's there's finding an irreducible
and feasible certificate which which
will produce the minimal certificate but
you know it the best we can do right now
is exponential time but here there's
there's two other techniques we have
which which actually involves just
solving either a linear number of convex
programs or a constant number of convex
programs and this is the structure that
we see in the problems in our domain
okay and in particular let me tell you a
little bit about the last one okay and
I'll just give it through example so
imagine that this was the graph
corresponding to the robot motion
planning example each each circle
corresponds to a region which is
represented by this this set of convex
constraints and imagine that this is the
goal region so let's say you're you're
the SAP solver came up with a path to
the goal region you invoke the convex
solver to check the feasibility and it
came out as being infeasible okay now
what we can do is basically find working
backwards the shortest infeasible prefix
okay the general intuition being that
you know if you have a have this
particular portion of the path which
cannot be executed by the robot right
it's not consistent with the dynamics
then it doesn't matter what happens
before right you want to be able to make
sure that you rule that out you don't
have you don't come up with an
alternative path from the starting state
that goes back and tries to repeat this
okay and so there's a natural order
that's imposed by the structure of this
graph that allows us to extract these
infeasible prefixes okay and in fact it
turns out that in thinking about the Sat
problem this ordering constraint imposed
from the application defines a subclass
of Sat problems that are called that the
correspond of boolean formulas that are
positively ordered unit okay so many of
you would know what what positive unit
boolean functions are which is with
respect to a certain variable if you
flip it from zero to a one then if you
hadn't
assignment for the original problem it
remains an assignment for the new one
and in the case of positively ordered
unit there's an ordering in which you
flip the variables okay and in this
particular instance the the boolean
variables encode which region you're in
and the ordering essentially is is an
ordering derived from essentially a
reverse BFS from the goal State okay so
so anyway so the the gist of this is
that you can solve only a convex number
of convict a constant a constant number
of convex programs and and here are
essentially the two convex programs you
have to solve to find this certificate
and I'll skip the details let me just
show you what you can do with this so in
practice you can solve problems that on
the one hand sac based methods are not
very good at for exist previous type a
but are not very good at when you when
the number of real variables is large
and optimization based tools are not
very good at when the number of
boolean's is large okay so we can get
several orders of magnitude speed-up we
can actually doing interesting
applications like so this is the one I
was telling you earlier and maybe I
should pause this and just replay go
back okay so so here I'm playing this is
the state estimation where you have two
drones as an this particular one does
has no protection against the attacks so
you see the drone fall down when when
the attack on the IMU is initiated okay
and in this case it's exactly the same
trajectory but you but what happens is
it just wobbles for a second and then
it's able to reconstruct the state using
the remaining sensors and then fly okay
and so what we're able to do here is
essentially run a Sat solver with a
convex optimization in a loop that's
that's fast enough that you can do
something that looks like real time
control here and being able to isolate
attacked sensors and recover from it all
right so I'll conclude now so
there's towards being doing correct by
construction synthesis of controllers or
plans I think being able to combine
stock based methods with with convex
optimization seems to be a really
promising route including being able to
apply this to things like model creative
control on the verification side this is
not something I talked about but we have
online algorithms for monitoring
properties over streams that do
essentially a constant amount of work
per sample on the stream and you can use
this for monitoring at run time
we have you know there's also work that
we have on doing being able to do this
runtime monitoring and then switching
between so-called safe and advanced
controllers so imagine you have a neural
network based controller that you
haven't quite verified and you don't
know how to verify exactly but you have
something that is maybe a less
complicated but more safe and lower
performance controller and we can
actually do runtime monitoring and then
switch between these from the advanced
controller to a safe controller so as to
to maintain the robot in a safe
operating condition and then there's
also some work that we've been doing in
using online learning to be able to
learn models of the environment and then
use them for adaptation and also taking
AI algorithms for clustering and lift
them to the logical level so that you
can you could monitor data streams and
and then do unsupervised learning over
them to to identify clusters but then
also give the cost clusters labels as
logical formulas so that you can use
those logical formulas in in designing
controllers for the for the environments
that are characterized by this data okay
so I'll stop there and I'm happy to take
any questions if there is time and I'm
around at Berkeley and in the program so
happy to talk to you offline as well
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
right so I so the question is what do
you do when you have an advanced
controller where you may not be able to
verify its correct operation okay so so
that the typical thing one does is you
construct an conservative abstraction of
what this advanced controller does and
that gives you a safety envelope so you
know that that's maybe the controller is
actually going to be safe but you
conservatively assume that it's that it
may do something unsafe and then violate
the safety specification and then at
that point you switch to the safe
controller so I have to say I mean
that's the question was you know what
happens when you combine partial
observability or noisy sensor data right
now is these state estimates with doing
having to do something like this right
and yeah at this point I don't have a
good answer to this right so we can do
this when we have when the sensors are
assumed to be perfect and we have full
observability of the system okay right
which doesn't hold in practice and then
we have some solutions for dealing with
the case where you have may have a
verified controller but then you have
noise ease of faulty sensors right but
now combining these two I think is an
open problem
Hey
[Applause]